hello welcome to see you playing Grand
Master dommatina kisses even sure rich I
think the shower is right here yep to
670 this is roughly as his rating let's
see I had a italian game against him in
an earlier game when I had a pretty good
position if i remember correctly so
let's see what we get we get this time
it's the usual slow build-up typical of
the Italian let's see what happens okay
so this is this kind of position get
this quite often him why does not not
playing for for any any big advantage
here anyways just happy to have a good
build-up am and rock the eighth that's
stupid I just I'd have to go d5 that's
stupid it's very very stupid more simply
and this is the kind of stuff that makes
this interesting for why players because
but black you sometimes you get out you
cannot fall asleep yeah because this is
just such a nothing opening you don't
really pay attention and then it happens
that this is you fall into stuff like
that I have to play the 5-meter lame
with no problems i guess and care now
now it's tricky and it's CN i think
after you go d 5 takes takes Knight c4
maybe but I don't think that f6 is a big
deal anyway you have to play this
position now let's see what happens
try to be the quickie and his position
my night only four is good but it's also
technically somewhat unstable I wonder
have taken one year 50 nice nice one so
I have to he wants to ok check ok so I
cannot take them but if I just go back
how does he keep the default pawn don't
think don't think he can looking for
something I don't know
some night takes right choice there's
some big trickery that I don't
understand no I don't see it so I'm
taking it check Johnny this is youporn
anything for white I don't think so ok
c6 ok what to do I think I'll just ok
King you 3s may be coming here let's see
if I can get rid of this
takes rook takes i think is that you
poorness more we can assign I just pick
it up or not at least if he is I get to
find something now otherwise i'll
probably just pick it up yeah I have
zero out of two against him but I know
that I had at least one totally winning
position so let's see what happens okay
so we tried some immediate
counter-attack is I don't know look
before or what is the idea I have bee
hive then also have g5 he just has a
girl's endgame here let's see what he is
doing to fight him
sorbed is six so I can take it with
check or play b5 I think I'll start with
been five here okay g5 if he goes up
rookie three looks good so I'm doing
this and now c5 in the rook doesn't have
any good square it just has to has to go
there and see for again it doesn't have
a good square now I'm bring the king of
my it looks very good I have some talent
and sporting those completely winning
endings but I really hope I'm managing
this one
my dears rook a six and then King a 4 B
3 the good thing is he has absolutely no
counter play okay yeah I think there's
nothing wrong with this white resigns
okay yeah I'm happy with this even
though I screwed up the opening allowing
this deform but then the ending was was
pretty okay hey I was just in tube
stupid move up the end you have to play
the five year of course now my initial
reaction was I will not stop doing this
because I saw this little line but after
f6 I'm totally fine here absolutely fine
he has no big idea because this kind of
thing is not not very promising anyway
yeah and then I thought okay let's go up
the eighth for us and then then he had
d4 and yeah this is just stupid just
very stupid new group d 8 and now I am
struggling I'm really struggling and
this is what's the relatively best but
it is a shaky position the night only
four is shaky I just am at some point he
has he has pulled his good position here
white should be better him okay have six
trying to get some play no a 3m the
computer wants to take I would have
taken with the night I guess and then it
dries 95 mm yeah that looks good Queen
move is not a very happy move yeah I
mean this is not possible Jack so then I
would have to take with this and that
suit looks plain ugly and the computer
wants to do this but this looks blah poo
oh and now I wouldn't have played this
move and so this is the thing he has to
take now and he has to take on f6 this
is the the way for him to punish my bed
owning a 3 is a bit bit lame but maybe
it's still good for him yeah the engine
wants to take now this is actually a
cute line Knight takes Knight takes pawn
takes and now this for d4 night everyone
d 3 it's a teapot is pretty strong seems
to be okay for me okay i played this
move and again you should take on f6 and
then he went with this which is in fact
not that bad for me this night f2 was
the good reply if he takes with the king
I've probably kicked him and this is ok
I have counter play in the center yeah
he went with this and now if I go back
he cannot keep this pawn anymore it was
quite lucky that I had this this is
trick night f2 I didn't see 95 at all
and here here i have the last slightly
slightly more comfortable position but
it did it should be a draw really i
think he was playing a little bit too
optimistically and i only hear realize
that he's fighting for the drawer i
guess after this this is pretty clear
that that white is struggling that you
porn is a weakness check I'm not sure
where it gets lost him the check the
engine is already giving a loss here for
white and I think it's very difficult he
has no counter play and will be he will
be a porn down check and I think here
here it's losing maybe he can defend a
better or not maybe he definitely can
defend better at the beginning of this
ending with here we're dealing with the
loss pollution as black it's just easily
promoting stuff and the easiest way to
Vinny is probably to play some look here
and then go with the King up but you can
also push the pawns its it should should
win we know I win as well it's easier
though to just promote both pawns
okay happy with this win against a very
high rated opponent thanks for watching